okay hello and welcome to this video
playing cave-in 50 Kevin 50 got him
caro-kann two nights 25 for I was Queen
more so always funny Queen f5 that's
what they normally do no doesn't he
doesn't okay then why did she go Queen
g5 in the first place hmm okay
I mean the queen is not in a super
comfortable situation now
yeah 95 I would love to play that the g2
is hanging
[Music]
hmm yeah that is not really nice I'm a
little bit skeptical about allowing the
double ponds him but Bishop b2 is the
lamest move ever yeah I kind of ahead 95
in mind but it was just drop on
what a shame what a shame
really yeah Black has of course some
very okay position now what did i do
there a bishop III was was not very well
thought out
yeah this is just an equal position
right well sometimes you have to do this
pressing water out of stone you just
want to prevent a jump to f4 you know
nate is just equal unfortunately
my dears to play c4 without a long night
before
okay sure I'm not sure that he needed to
allow this queenside weakening it is a
slight weakening okay so maybe can play
in Fishers style rook a - and no I
cannot Kim
I don't want night a 4 or c4 to happen
it's still pretty much a non kind of a
non-event here this pollution nothing
happens maybe just wondering if the two
might be uncovered after c5 or e5 idea
that's why I went rogue d1 quickly and
I'm a little bit lower on time so I did
not want to invest a lot of time yeah he
just wants to trade down the board that
much I gathered okay now I can actually
do this now actually it's a bit annoying
now for Hermia that's a double attack c6
and g6 so he almost has to take and that
is not so desirable it's still off of
course very equal and now this is a bit
of a shame him if I go before now he
will put the bishop on to d5 and then
just stay there forever so my pawns I
probably have to do this
not that I'm totally sure of it
Bishop what about Bishop to a5 that
threatens not much unfortunately yeah I
would have prevented that you're just
just for general on general grounds
black probably it's not really a big
deal but
okay is there some way for me to exploit
their this night position I would I
would absolutely love to have more time
that would be a good good thing here
it's maybe a maybe I can create it suits
one Bishop to c6 it's going to be awful
and now what just winning the night yeah
you should have prevented that that made
that that made it at least a lot more
problematic firm that's why I was yeah
waiting you know there was highly
desirable getting this here and yeah so
let's have a look there I'm really
unhappy about the opening like so yeah
Bishop c4 I'm an idiot yeah just this
one of course why didn't I do that and
now he has to do some yeah some probably
not ideal maneuvers is better than the
game but even here I am just just Kobe
should beat or something other that was
that was not a good idea here I just
don't have anything great maybe a c4
actually makes a lot of sense
I didn't play well here in this way 95
is possible the immediate 95 he can take
and that's absolutely useless
yeah maybe should be to is of course I
mean I just did not register that c4 is
a good month yeah yeah be should be to
is just extremely me Kia now he has
equalized easily yeah
again we saw it it's not an automatic
draw yeah we just can always continue
and try to set some problems of course
this is this is equal yeah
claiming anything here is six oops sorry
a six castling Knight b6 that must be
all fine I think it was fine for black
until the the very ending the a droopy
ones kind of just make a quick move and
she decided to trade everything which is
yeah maybe not the best possible way to
play it but certainly an okay way so C 4
is given here as an alternative okay yam
what I did not see you is that after c5
this is maybe an idea or isn't it and I
have six okay yeah and I'm not totally
stopping this yeah okay I mean 97
doesn't work but like there's a way out
for the night because the bishop can
help it okay I went G for and 95 which
she took bishop c2 and maybe Here I am
Bishop f3 is actually a good alternative
could have done that okay though so I
went c4 he took it take take yeah here I
would have liked this one but I didn't
quite see the benefit really after after
something like this I probably have to
take you know okay so I took him and now
um you should avoid Bishop a5 I mean
just move the knight Knight b6 97 after
this say that is really really bad I
mean maybe it is not playable the engine
says white wins here just fled out +2
I'm not too surprised
I mean how to see how does he save it so
it's really difficult to say so knocking
of to
yeah the engine already sees that the
night has no way out Jake Jake I just
have no way out
strapped on aid yeah that was quite
honest unnecessary for black to lose the
game but I'm a little bit I'm less than
enthusiastic hopefully yeah I mean this
is extremely obvious yeah the ship see
form should just play that okay guys
thanks for watching